so i think about the supreme court's
recent ruling on
uh workplace equality pertaining to
uh same-sex relationships and
transgender and their argument that
while
sex does include these things therefore
the previous
you know laws do protect these
characteristics
and they used uh interestingly
what they did was and and look i'm all
for workplace equality stuff like that
but i think it's interesting that the
supreme court said because
you can't discriminate someone based on
their relationship
unless you're targeting them based on
sex
it is a protected category to be gay
lesbian bisexual etc
you remember when they did that yeah
yeah yeah the reason number is a very
technical argument
right um the reason it brings up
specifically though is they're changing
the definitions of words
and when the definition of the word
changes then the amendment changes
afterwards so if you can't change a
constitutional amendment
you can change the meaning of words what
is white supremacy
so now they've made it so that white
supremacy is quite literally
time hard work and that's that's these
things have existed for decades these
ideas that have been seeded and are
expanding and are now becoming
mainstream
and how dangerous and raw so you're
referring to that's exactly
the left was saying that uh hard work
and individuality and like having a
stable family and all those things are
elements of white culture right which is
something an
ardent racist actual rights white
supremacist an alt-right person would
say that
that that this is what differentiates
white culture and that's why it's better
so how harmful and i think that view is
totally wrong
but the left was promoting that view in
agreement with that
it was on the website of the national uh
african-american museum from the
smithsonian
yes so that's yeah so so
so you're gonna say to me that you can
over hype the the problem we're facing
here
i don't think so i think to me this is a
serious existential threat
and i think the easiest example is i
know it's a bit cliche for my audience
because i bring it up
relatively often but there's a reason
why i do
my i grew up hearing stories about life
before loving v virginia and the civil
rights act
and it sounds scary for for my family
and california democrats just voted to
repeal
prop 209 so it's going to referendum
quite literally repealing their civil
rights law
for at the state level for public
employment and schools and stuff
so the left is actually this is
interesting you're familiar with the
term reactionary
in the proper context it's funny so the
the left likes to point out you know
right wing reactionaries it's a
reference to the french
french revolution those who reacted to
the revolution and opposed it
so reactionary typically means you want
to keep the status quo and prevent the
revolution
but what the left is doing is actually
turning the clock backwards
on freedom of speech and civil rights
they're quite literally a reactionary
movement
that everything you just said about
ardent racists and white supremacists
the democrats of today are trying to go
back to what the democrats of the 1950s
believed in a weird and slightly
different kind of way
like they genuinely believe that white
culture
you know inherently endorses or produces
hard work
and saving for the future and they're
guilty about it or something
i guess to be fair though there still
are to some there's still
some racist beliefs in society that are
prevalent among
white people uh white conservatives and
also i
always have to bring this up because it
is i talk a lot about it you do
as well leftist cancel culture uh free
speech issues on campuses
there are also tons and tons and tons of
cases of conservatives flipping out
about
professor leftist professor says
something like america is bad or like
i don't support the flag or something
and what happens
every time all the cons not everyone i
don't do this maybe you don't do this no
we're not conservatives but the the
freak out among the
a certain kind of turning point usa
crowd who
in every other context says cancel
culture is bad like oh this is we need
to fire that we need to hold this person
accountable like it's so lame it's so
pathetic
and so many conservatives i'm i'm
reminded of when i hate it
i'm reminded of when trump said jail
time for burning the flag right
an issue that has been litigated by it
could not be clear the supreme court has
said
you can burn the flag right it's a it's
a it's an open and shut first amendment
case
and it really does it it's annoying that
that pres
it's annoying and wrong that president
trump would say otherwise and that the
conservative people would freak out
about that so
i think you look i i wouldn't burn the
flag
right i i not a fan of people burning
the flag but i am a fan of the freedom
it represents burning the flag
and so that's a part of living in a free
society where an individual as long as
it's your property
that's a big thing because i remember i
was at some event where they they were
trying to light a flag on fire
and then some right-wing guy took it
back because it was actually stolen from
him
and people were like it's a free speech
it's a free speech and then they were
like you stole the flag from some it's
not your property
if you want to have your own property to
burn you do it but they were trying to
you know
make some kind of it's important as a
free speech point because
this is this is a a country that
protects free speech on paper it needs
to be the first amendment to a greater
degree than any country on earth in a
very serious way you you have
hate crime laws that are much more
serious that actually do criminalize
outright speech in other jurisdictions
in other countries
you can't libel laws are in other some
other countries in australia
in the uk where you can't journalists
can't do their jobs they can't say true
things about people because they're
going to be sued for it
um this is a country that protects free
speech to a really
enviable degree and it's rare and it's
uncommon and it's not historically
like free speech is new i mean even in
america for world world war one
uh people who are protesting world war
one are handing out leaflets they got
thrown in jail and the supreme court
said that was fine
now they've backed off that and we have
currently the most wildly pro-free
speech
supreme court that has ever existed we
have the most pro-free speech
authority of like legal authority that
has ever existed on earth and that's a
very good thing
you know we used to have an office of
censorship right and their slogan was
silence accelerates victory right that
was world war ii
right so what a lot of these a lot of
people don't realize is that our current
understanding of free speech is
really new we like this is a country
that is a first amendment this is what's
really amazing about the first amendment
is that
it meant almost nothing a long time ago
it actually took
the the rulings of the supreme court
better understandings of freedom and
liberty
to bring us to this point is what's
really funny when they criticize free
speech warriors
the left they're like the free speech
warriors the far right reaction blah
blah
like when you talk about the inception
of this country the bill of rights came
what like like a decade or so
after yeah the country was formed and
even then they weren't really properly
enforced in
in that sense the alien sedition acts
were terrible yeah
well uh so i'm not super familiar but i
i to my to uh the point i was going for
is
we had obscenity laws yes we had moral
moral authoritarianism
we were it was a very religious culture
and
we move we move forward through the
years we eventually come up
come across people like um you know
frederick douglass
and and you know right anti-slavery
stuff where they really challenge the
idea of what it means to be free and
what our constitution really means
and even then we still did not have
outright free speech the way we know it
today
that's what i remember like looking at
like the viet you know and then i think
it was the 70s
or was it when when were they doing the
big free speech stuff on berkeley
uh yes the 60s 1960s 60s yeah so my
understanding i was reading about this
i read up i talk about it a lot in the
book
so do you know do you know when the
supreme court like officially gave us
our
most current iteration of free speech uh
well the most recent
decisions that establish a very broad
understanding of free speech are really
the uh
it's the westboro baptist uh
in my view because there the supreme
court said you can go you're
on public property on the road you can
shout the most vile things you can
possibly imagine
in the most sympathetic context for the
victim you're shouting them at
military people who've been killed yeah
and you can shout
awful things and that is protected by
the first amendment if that speech is
protected by the first amendment
everything that is offensive to the to
the social justice
is obviously protected if that's
protected so it's interesting that was
the
early is that 21st century is that the
free speech the founders
envisioned no i probably it's not
probably some of them i mean there was
like there was a
the quaker ethos the voltaire
enlightenment ethos that
i may disagree or even hate what you
have to say but i will fight to the
death to defend it
yeah there's always been free speech
you're right to say it you're righteous
there have always been free speech
dissidents in society
even in even in like intense kind of
medieval europe
like like geneva like kind of uh you
know john calvin
obscenity type there there were some
people saying no we should have free
speech
um but for most of human history for
most people it was i mean even it wasn't
even just if you offend the religious
stories of the king
if you badmouth your neighbors they
would come kill you i mean there was a
in
iceland right there's a court to to
adjudicate um disputes between rival
clans that are that are insulting
other people yeah that's i think that's
the basis of there it was kind of
anarchist and
we won't get into it um and i guess then
cool you said right but
but you you would fight uh you would you
would fight duel you'd challenge people
to duels even up
up through the early part of the 1800s
in america you would challenge people to
duels if they defend if their speech
offended you so there was no
understanding of free speech there was
it was a small number of people who
really held to that and we met we
managed to make that the law of the land
for our country somehow and it's great
could we so what you're saying is we
could resolve a lot of our problems we
brought back dueling
that would get i think i said that i'm
kidding i'm kidding i got smash brothers
tournaments or something
right well i guess the the issue with
dueling was that you quite literally
silenced the person forever and they
would never
then speak all of you again in uh
stephen pinker's book about the decline
of violence um
he argues that uh dueling stopped
basically because the younger generation
thought it was really dumb
and they were like why are you killing
people
so it like became uncool you know we we
you mentioned that we have a very very
free speech country and uh
you know we're talking a bit about how
maybe it's not the founding fathers
envisioned but there are a lot of
problems that come with it
fake news i mean and that's one of the
first things we talked about in this
you know in this in this uh live stream
the covington stuff
yeah so we do have libel laws
but the covington kids notably nick
sandman who's suing these news outlets
he's won technically i think it's a
settlement
exactly so they weren't court victories
but
i think it's fair to say that that is in
a sense a victory because often the goal
is to force a settlement yeah you know
they sued for what 250 million
yeah because they're not going to get
that but nowhere close right
so i think that's something they they
got something that i'm sure was pretty
good
i don't i think the people who are
pointing out that it was nuisance
payout so uh basically that means it's
cheaper for you know cnn or the
washington post i think that's who paid
out right
yeah yeah it's cheaper for them to just
pay them to go away than to deal with
the court case but i'd imagine they had
a little bit more than that
because i think they risked going to
discovery
you know the judge had ruled that some
of them were were good and that meant
that if it moved forward
then likely nick salmon's lawyer would
sue and get access to their
communication the judge changed his mind
in the i can't remember it was whichever
case was first and i can't remember it
was cnn or washington post i think it
was washington post just can't remember
but he
he had a ruling basically saying that uh
i mean
it's a complicated case because you have
to establish uh because really the like
the
the the libelous party to some degree is
the native american man is is who said
you know who said that i was being
i was b and he's an editor in prey but
you don't go after him he doesn't have
any money he doesn't have two [ __ ] are
up against so
cnn and washington the mainstream
outlets that first reported on it
they're relying on which is essentially
a false witness someone who gave them
false information
so to what degree are they responsible
what degree are they liable for
reporting on that for reporting what
someone told them they saw
do you know what i mean so that was a
little bit of my just even though
they jumped the gun on the story and
then you get to well why are you even
writing this story this isn't
this is there's no confirmation it's not
a public and this isn't a public person
is it a matter of public importance
it's not and that matters be that nick
sandman is not a public person because
the standard is different
whether you're exactly or a public
person a private person so it raised a
lot of interesting questions
so they decided and then also the things
being described are they actually
are they just opinion characterizations
like is he smirking or smiling
that's not going to be a factual
assertion so the facts the only thing
i think the judge decided was maybe a
factual assertion was was he blocking
the path
right um and then you were gonna so then
they settled
so you were gonna be able to mount
probably sandman's attorneys were going
to be able to amount
i would think depend you know the
jurisdiction might be sympathetic to him
anyway
right that was a factual assertion that
they got wrong i think they may have
actually got more than people realize
and i mean you know when i say a little
you don't think so no maybe i have no
idea you know why
discovery probably would have cost those
companies so much money
i mean i i wonder i don't know about
reason but you guys have like a slack or
something where you communicate with
other employees
and do you say things that you would
hope and pray would never become public
dear god yes right now imagine what
washington post and cnn are saying yeah
yeah
yeah they're probably thinking how much
will we lose if it
turns out that our employees were
laughing and mocking the kid and saying
who cares he's a nazi well we know what
they said
publicly on twitter people affiliated
with with uh with cnn at least
and that's them being careful though
yeah so and like i want to punch this
kid imagine if they were
imagine what like one person posted a
picture of a wood chipper with blood
coming out and they were like you know
a guy who worked for disney i guess i
don't i don't know be careful
jake tapper was the first like the first
blue checkmark person
to retweet my article when i came out
with this i
the mainstream media did a bad job with
the story but swiftly corrected
themselves
there are still outlets that are more
like ideological like
there was an article for slate there was
an article for dead stone that
still to this day maintained that nick
sandman was a racist who
got in this guy's face and so i uh a lot
of criticism and i'm plenty critical to
mainstream media all the time
but this one's it's like okay they i see
where they got it wrong
but there are there are actually greater
media sins in this that just don't get
talked about for sure that are that
that persist to this day i'm gonna say
something that sh that should be
considered a compliment i guess but i
consider jake tapper our
like media d student like he actually
there's not as bad
yeah he's not nearly as bad he's a d is
bad
but he gets a passing grade just like
yeah i like tapper i think he's a good
reporter yeah
i think he i think he he i think uh i
give him a d
maybe a d plus that's harsh it is yeah
well it's not as bad as a lot of the
people you know the grades i'd give
but you know he's he's said and done
things in the past that are particularly
like ill-informed and bad i think he
tweets commentary from a variety of
sources which is uh very valuable if
you're in the mainstream you're not just
listening to people in your own echo
chamber um
he has tweeted a lot of my articles yeah
yeah so that's why i give a passing
grade
i guess it's because i have like a lot
of disdain for a lot of these media
companies
yeah so uh you know so anyway
just to wrap up that previous point
about internal slacks
i've i've worked for some of these
companies and for those other families
slack is just
it's like discord i guess for
corporations you know it's it's a
communication server i love how that's
how you describe it to your audience
it's like g-check this audience i don't
think what it was
so uh yeah i don't know people know what
discord is everybody uses discord to
some degree or a lot of people do
it's a popular thing like you know on
reddit people mention their discords
so slack is is relatively similar but
i've worked for some of these companies
man i tell you if these if these
private logs ever got published or
spicy yeah that's what you got to delete
they should you should delete i mean you
can't just companies should definitely
care you can't get rid of oh i guess
they stay and like it well if it was a
subpoena you could get you'd have to use
a penis slack
i guess you could yep this get you you
get the servers through it right now
yeah
and and even if they've erased them man
you can recover all that stuff
you can recover it it just depends on
how far you're willing to go yeah
yeah but so here's why i think nick
salmon may have got more people realize
if the judge is saying these are good
we're going to move forward the next
step is discovery
and they're going to say we want to know
what you were saying behind the scenes
about nick sandman because they want to
prove
intent malice actual malice meaning did
these people these news organizations
know what they're producing was false
now we don't know but discovery will get
you know and then
i don't think they did i thought they
get they got taken in by a by a
believable and
credible seeming witness who was there
and told them something that was totally
wrong
and that's a tough i mean as a
journalist as someone who writes
articles that's a tough position to end
up in
i mean it wasn't an anonymous sword they
said they just said this guy said this
yeah but but a lot of people wrote
stories not even contacting sandman i'm
sorry without even contacting
phillips the native american guy they
just said in a viral video a young man
is seen blocking the path
and smirking but phillips gave an
interview to a couple outlets
and then they so then there i mean i do
i you quote
you block quote uh something from a
different article
that's a problem yeah so so a lot of
these outlets
didn't make some some of the outlets
that wrote about this didn't reference
phillips's statements they
they launched off of them to make the
actual factual assertion
so this is the problem of free speech
particularly with our very rigorous
defamation protections anti-slap laws
that's a was it strategic lawsuit
against public participation yep
a lot of states have this and it's like
you super defamation and they say your
public failures
goodbye don't care you're out gets
dismissed really really quickly
and that creates the fake news problem
which results in
chaos yeah i mean this is a tough line
because like i said i i don't want to
draw the defamation standard a lot
tighter because then you can chill
important discussions that you can the
ability to hold powerful people
accountable
i mean that harvey weinstein that story
could not be written
in another country it just couldn't it
would the the lie no one would print it
even here there was some effort to shut
it down
uh to threaten those kinds of things
yeah so it it now
the the difference is so how do we i do
but i believe in privacy
very strongly so the question now is in
the social media age
how do we protect to the extent we even
can
privacy for non-public people
i don't actually i don't care if peop if
people there has to be a high threshold
of just allowing you to say wrong crazy
stuff about famous people
for people like sandman who's just a
regular person how do you protect
those kinds of people's right to have
privacy or not be written about or
characterized in this way
without expanding libel is there some
other way you can do it
that's the kind of thing i think about a
lot these days or it could there be a
a uh or like you know like gawker
publishing like
actually humiliating video like sex
videos i mean they did that not even to
hulk hogan but just a random woman who
was
assaulted while she was drunk in a space
they did it to a guy who was an
executive i think at conde nast
oh yeah that was they outed out yeah
when he or whatever when yeah
he was uh something outside he was being
blackmailed that was terrible and they
participated in this black
that exactly it was horrible they did so
many horrible horrible
horrible things and actually they did
ultimately they would they i mean they
very much deserved what they got
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you